[Music]
hi oh hi hey there hi how are you we
don't look at each other oh okay sorry I
was confused okay go ahead hi how's it
going I'm Pam my name's Thomas is there
two of you guys are one this one okay oh
hello how you doing good and yourself
not bad are you from the San Diego area
yeah my whole life you oh I live up in
San Marcos just north of here I only
been up there for five years now do you
want to answer some questions yeah okay
how are you doing really how am i doing
really what did you meet your wife met
her square dancing square dance yep her
mother introduced us to her oh yeah I
have been square dancing for a while and
her mother wanted to her to learn to
square dance and so she brought her to a
square dance class and I was just
sitting around sweet well she asked
first if I dance with her and I said
sure I'll I'll dance with her and that
was the start of it about a month later
I threw away my black book
I met her about 56 years ago we've been
married 52 now that long
yep come on got six kids and 29
grandkids on one great grandkid
do you say 29 yep grandkids yep my 29th
grandchild a girl born two weeks ago a
little over two weeks ago yeah it is oh
yeah it is a big family hope to have a
family that big but not like 29 kids to
itself but like no mine I mean they're
my kids
yeah like one kid and then they can make
the rest okay if you have one they're
not gonna make 29 yeah I sure would
what's the most painful thing you've
been told probably that I would in the
mount to anything yeah yeah I'm normally
odd just brushed up off of it is it
always someone that you know and like
love and care for oh yeah I was some it
was somebody that I thought highly of at
the moment but now I'm just like all
right next question
hey what's going on hi how are you I'm
all right where are you from Scotland no
why that's so dope is this your first
time visiting my first time yeah fannia
yeah came I'm from New York
I'm visiting a buddy out here just
imagine the cameras aren't here the
reserved conversation ok thank you guys
well yeah what's your name
Mariah what's your name Sandra I heard
you talking like behind and at you
reminds you have kind of like Susie
Carmichael
um regrets always just kind of like I
don't know kind of like it but not like
as raspy so Susie which one is that the
little black girl oh okay thank you bang
yeah your voice is kind of like a little
scratchy so I do stings so that I like I
like people usually say that they know
that because of my voice but I haven't
heard that before and I'm more like
jazzy soul anyway so that's kind of an
interesting like comparison biggest
question the most important question of
the entire interview have you seen the
Loch Ness monster no okay because I know
as a kid I want to be a cryptozoologist
and I my dream is defined oh we love
actually near where he's supposed to be
where all the sightings are located no
why what's how do you live in tales
write that down even hounds Berg some
very bad do you believe in Bigfoot and
yeah I believe in a most fine chance
you're believing what most things that
other people don't believe I really do
you believe in God yes you do you uh you
have a specific religion oh it's good
yeah you're Catholic so so I would I
didn't grow up religious but I ended up
becoming a Christian right after yeah
right around three years after college
why um Wow right on YouTube I testily
alright it's always a girl right so I
ended up being a girl I didn't I heard
about Jesus and I heard about God but I
was just like no it's a bunch of bull
it's much a religion yeah and I only
thing to do with it and God hates this
God hates this but I was just like I'm
not into it but I ended up I ended up as
I dated this girl for about a year and
she broke my heart and a lot of people
can get over breakups and that's cool
good for them but I couldn't so I
actually like I know we're going so deep
I actually wrote out a suicide note to
my dad I was gonna end my life
and I will plan out how I was going to
do it and I realized in that moment that
if I went through it that I don't know
where I was going or if there was
anywhere to go so instead of having an
emotional moment where God says I'm real
I decided to give my life to somebody
who actually wanted so yeah I'm pretty
close to the Lord I'm pretty tight but
ever since then he's completely giving
me more joy more peace more and more
more of a heart to love people rather
than shovel religion down their throat
so very cool so how how do you like the
Catholic Church like what relationship
with God I can't agree over at some
point in my life and like my sister we
both grew up Catholic she just to say
that she's not really into anymore but I
know I just came back so I just think
it's nice to believe in something and I
think that's like what's the what's the
point and kind of like what do you think
is afterlife if you don't believe in
anything that's not really a very nice
way to live they have always believed
that heaven and I think it's like a
comforter and you think that affects
your day-to-day life yeah it's awesome
it's super encouraging yeah it's nice
hear your story about coming close to
God does it's a nice thing to hear I
appreciate that and do you feel like you
feel like you have a relationship of God
like a personal one that affects your
day-to-day life
well I prayed like daily pretty much the
boss at night and stuff yeah so have you
ever had your heart broken
oh tell me about it I think well
obviously like everybody has had their
heart broken but he cheated on me a few
times so I just left
I had like held on to a relationship way
longer than I needed to you know to me
wow I had a partner like a while ago and
we were technically on a break but I
knew there was something going on with
them yeah I was one of their co-workers
and I was like this is weird I feel like
you guys are a little close and long
story short they ended up like making
out during one of our breaks and then
they went on a date on the second one
and so it wasn't like a fully cheating
but it just yet it still was like I knew
something was up you know but they made
me feel like I was crazy for believing
that you know so I get that I'm sorry to
hear that
that sucks are you from San Diego yeah
I'm from San Diego oh are you a freshman
yeah oh nice but what's the best advice
you've ever been given honestly probably
from my younger sister she just told me
to be yourself and like not try to
impress anybody because no matter what
people are you want people to love you
for who you are and not someone you're
trying to be
because you don't want to have to act
for your whole life so I think that was
like that impacted me a lot yeah yeah
definitely that's like good advice okay
anything you really want to know
actually you sound really interesting
you might like give me your phone
numbers of the career that came out okay
do you want me to like tell you now I've
just half did this yeah we but yeah you
sound really cool all right yeah you
feel this is a really cool yeah I get to
know someone your name was Lauren right
yeah
all right nice nice made you one guy
once told me and he told me that I was
shy because English is not my first
language so I was shy with talking with
him and he told me that if I don't
practice like I don't do it I will
regret it because if if I do it I'm able
to meet another person's like you if I
don't if I I don't dare to speak English
I would I wouldn't be talking with you
right you know how are you doing but
really I'm doing good but I feel like I
could be doing better I'm just kind of
trying to figure out my place in this
world
yeah
trying to see where that goes
I'm still young so hopefully I figured
out soon though okay well okay I think
we're we all are figuring out what to do
in life so yeah yeah thank you makes me
feel not alone
what do you do for fun i watch youtube
videos i watch their ayahs videos okay
what do you do now
are you student no I just work what do
you do i do nothing my job sucks I
thought he was cool he had a good vibe
you know and like he travelled a lot of
something I want to do something we had
in common he met his wife and they've
been married for like like 56 years and
that's a long time that's not like many
people know I do this that's loud that's
not rule of right there
well she was very nice and friendly seem
very open she wants to get in to a
career where she can work with animals I
feel like to have 29 grandkid you have
to be a shape folk by it have all them
kids running around there you have to be
you have to be able to move around a lot
so probably like you stay in shape tall
she's probably wearing shorts big smile
I think I could see her with cornrows
I guess I'm wrong on that one
that's Paulo seems pretty laid back I'm
feeling funny probably somebody got a
hot hang out with I don't know if that's
his lady but she's like you better have
the right answer here tattoos definitely
no medium height I don't know why stocky
he has a deep voice manly I guess
shorts and a tank top kind of guy he is
from Riverside so maybe not too much
style
[Laughter]
she seems comfortable in her own skin
and she seems secure enough to actually
do this or a lot of people go no I don't
wanna easy to talk to
I'm very inspiring hearing about his
struggles and journeys and stuff so yeah
really nice for the nice guy blonde hair
and kind of looking for fear I want to
go again
I want to guess again so our voice
immediately reminded me like Susie
Carmichael all right about average
height she probably just looks like a
grown up Susie Carmichael let me know
she looks like that's a bishop I look
like she's going through a lot but she's
still like strong and trying to to give
doing better like and I admire her
because I know I like I feel she's just
kind
he's an achiever because he got some
cool advice that he should keep
practicing his English and he did and
that's amazing because he sounds great
good job Carlos thank you he seems like
a very kind sweet soul she sounds like
she wants to help people it's really
cool like that so I want to hang out
with more like find out more she seems
really cool t-shirt swords maybe
come on they're like dirty blows I don't
know
alright are you doing good well no
cornrows but nice smile thank you what
did you think I don't know I just
thought cornrows ask me I'm Harold I'm a
cake me okay Kayla yeah
[Music]
that's know why and she's saying it's
time to go
[Laughter]
hey so I think we're both wrong oh nice
enough sorry you guys are joking
you are like I thought you where same
your English is great keep it up
coughing yeah I still look are like oh
yeah I like your voice thank you thank
you I bet you're doing longer hair for
some reason I don't know why I just
chopped it off so I've had your blonde
yeah look like it's you I grow it a red
beard I really do I have so much I could
show you a picture I play guitar and
sing so I play all oh I play all the
songs do you have a guitar you know a
guitar can we find a guitar I absolutely
could but see if it's hard do you know
many of the five friend she knows her
yeah my friend was like a little bit
like nervous to say hi
so I'll just I'll do it I like I knew
but hey like she's pretty dope okay so
much better darling just died right
what's up guys thanks for watching
another episode please let me know in
the comments if you liked the new
project I know it was a little bit out
there but hopefully in a good way I also
want to thank my cousin shed Amin for
helping me come up with this idea that's
pretty much it thank you guys again for
everything I'll see you next week